my
name is michael walker i'm a b-boy i'm a
break dancer
but i can do also some other dances but
my
main focus is uh is breaking
[Music]
i start a breaking in 1984 as
as a small kids in the hallways on the
streets
and then after after that i i started
practicing practicing with my friends my
next-door neighbors and then in
87 i stopped dancing i did some
martial arts some aikido some kung fu
and then in 97 i started breaking again
i was dancing in a crew called all-star
breakers
freezone optimal forma
even a bit optimal form i went to the
olympics in greece athens to do a show
and in 2001 i've worked with
uh john cd from
england from london on a small piece
and it was the first time actually i
was we were taking hip-hop breaking
into the theaters and that was my first
time
uh i was not breaking on the streets
but breaking in theaters in a theater
show
i make a piece with two good friends of
mine
mine dennis delano and lloyd mourinho
the piece called the offslog
in english i think it's called the exit
and it's based on all of the choices
people are making during life some
people from our
neighborhoods go to fight for
isis and come back to the neighborhood
so it's all old neighborhoods the piece
is
about why why did they
take that exit why
do they choose to take the taxes to go
fight with isis
and not just staying in
in the netherlands and do something
else because me
and the friends of mine we don't take
the taxi
we just stay where we are
working and stuff and also it's about
choices
[Music]
for me as a dancer with a disability
certain things i cannot do with my legs
but
it doesn't matter i will i will always
find
something that i can do
you